[Musique]
oui pas autant quand je voudrai ces
dernières trois ans j'ai eu
l'opportunité d'aller plus et j'adore
parce que bon ben c'est vraiment ma
famille à mes ancêtres connaître un peu
plus ma famille vivre paris par commune
touristes plutôt locale et 20 plaquages
adore l enfance j'adore la culture
française j'adore manger des crêpes
défendu jeudi sa démission
oui oui beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup la france mes parents
ont toujours parlé en français j'essaie
de double culture que je remercie
énormément parce que je crois que tous
les français qui viennent au mexique
tombe amoureux du mexique
et ça se passe pareil pour le mexique
active en france c'est des gens très
chaleureux qui qui reçoivent tout le
monde alors pareillement en france c'est
un pays où il ya beaucoup de personnes
différentes et en amérique on n'est pas
tellement mika salo
j'admire beaucoup la culture française
et l'histoire est complètement
différente alors c'est pour ça que mon
agence vivant
j'adore là où je suis né saint claude
jura
toute cette partie de chamonix j'adore
vraiment ce point et puis paris quelque
chose adorable mais je connais pas
autant que je vaux je prenne un jour la
voiture je le passe tout en voiture oui
bien sûr va toute la famille est là bas
j'ai mon père qui vit au mexique avec
moi mais je reste lui sont tous à paris
au jura alors oui bien sûr il va falloir
qu'il apprenne à parler dans l'amour
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut apprendre
à se respecter soi-même pour respecter
les autres
la famille la famille je crois aussi
être une personne positive
aider les autres tendre la main rien
espérer des autres quand on donne il
faut donner sans rien espérer
en échange la paix vivre en paix dormir
en paix
[Musique]